we're having a big show today Gary's
makeover what he came to me a couple of
weeks ago and he said that Brenda Cooper
from a they do a show called the
makeover show are they talking fashion
emergency yeah fashion emergency so they
wanted Baba Booey I said no because I
said let him do it on here we're going
on a new show right and she made him
over last night he said to me he said
I'm hiding from you because it's I want
you guys to see it on the air I can't
wait we have your eyebrows very casual
we're going to the Hamptons I want to
see the Hamptons over-the-top you know
it's the husband sports man who is ready
now with his makeover
let's meet Brenda Cooper first they
contacted us and said they'd like to do
a makeover on bababooey they see him and
say this guy is in drastic I don't know
but this is a Brenda right here so
Brenda took baba booey your first
impression of him that he's not as bad
as all you guys making is that right yes
well he lost some weight recently he was
very very charming yeah but Howard this
started by Brenda was home watching Andy
show and she just was like looking at my
hair and my clothes and she was like
itching to make me over you're right
right now I'll tell you why you're right
because
he's a producer of a successful radio
television show and I say to him all the
time no one respects him around here in
management I say you don't look like a
powerful guy you look like a kid it's
one thing if I dress a certain style
because that's I'm a performer
I said you're supposed to be a
businessman and you look like a child
thank you
let's see the first look Gary what is
the first look we're gonna see this is
Gary doing a makeover for Gary with his
look within the parameters of his
workplace working for you all right and
still being comfortable because he has
to work in the studio thank you okay
here we go first of all I'm wearing nice
clothing there's a lot of things that
went on you're Howard you're wearing
nice I like the clothes but your hair so
my hair has been a Jerrod string yes it
has there's not much you can do with him
straighten your hair Bubble Boy
chemically I guess there's nothing you
could do with those lips and teeth
that's what I keep saying that what
makeover can you do yeah I mean there's
nothing you can really change but you
can do something with his lips and teeth
you can't even get those lips over his
teeth well first of all did you notice
that did you notice that that big clump
of hair is missing between my eyebrows
yes now I have to
you see you're way too aware of that
that was not your problem made a major
change really but it was so curly too
bushy on camera it looks like it was ten
pounds heavier than it was you know the
ten pounds on camera yes yes suffers
from that problem yes a big way yes we
were blow drying out his hair and it was
fighting the curl I mean he it wanted to
go back to being curly I could see it he
has a big face though look at the size
of his face oh yeah that's better now it
looks good he knows what to do with that
bow it looks good
that's good yeah you're right Brenda
yeah he actually looks better when you
when you run your fingers we did it
straighten his hair and then and then my
geez trainer would you use a relaxer a
relaxer yes it looks more relaxed yes
doesn't know each hair looks relaxed yes
and I also had my eyebrows thinned out
what did your wife see this yeah she
loved it yeah yeah well it's just a
different hairstyle they cleaned up your
eyebrows right but what do you think the
outfit don't you think this is like
looks good yeah you look you look that's
a good outfit guy who does something for
a living yes yeah you look like you're
responsible would you like to see Gary
Dell'Abate going to the Hamptons
stammers I want to see the Hamptons I'll
take a break while you change okay this
is Baba Booey going to Oh for crying out
loud
keeps happening to your hair you keep
messing it up one second what is that I
my cousin Edwards here yeah he's been
doing my hair so Edwards a great
hairdresser but tell him he's got a he
keeps knocking it down into your face
right right I'm coming over to Brandon
I'll tell you stuff all right
look at that where's he going in the
Hamptons with that outfit his look as
you can tell right he doesn't look good
like that I have my feet yesterday
Howard first of all the jacket shouldn't
be buttoned it's too small on you the
shirt shouldn't be buttoned all the way
up to the top again thinks it should
well with the button-up yeah opened up a
book yeah sure this year your jacket has
to be opened up a little smaller we
decided that my colors are not summer no
yeah we're not sure what your colors are
they definitely not summer can I tell
you something interesting but yeah from
the fashion point of view this is
exactly the same silhouettes the same
shapes of clothing as the outfit that
looked good on him right it's just a
color it's yeah I have my feet in citrus
yesterday what is that about why would
your feet being citrus and what does I
got to do with the makeover they thought
I should have a manicure and a pedicure
and you know what I do have to admit my
cuticles were very bad shape on my I've
never once had a manicure and I've never
had a pedicure pedicure is cool I don't
need it I rub your feet I have gorgeous
feet I do it spam people say to me do
you have a
a cure what do you say what's wrong with
you I said I don't have that nice to
feel good there's this big copper bowl
yeah I'm feeding it and there's oranges
and lemons floating in it and what is
that for I don't know you should put
your mouth in there all right listen oh
there he is being bathed like a king
Oh who'd want to work on it and you know
what I have one really scary toenail
it's got a mind of its own and this poor
woman how to work on it Oh must throw up
it was like a rotten toenail I'm gonna
throw up from your feet probably foot
well anyway listen Baba Booey I like the
new haircut I think Brenda did you a
solid Brenda I want to thank you for
coming in you're a beautiful woman
you really are Baba Booey you want to
say something to Brenda for giving you a
brand new look I would say I want to
thank her and also she's just plain old
fun to hang out with me yeah yeah she's
a fun chair
congratulations on your makeover I like
the hair yeah the hair is good hard to
get used to but it's good yeah well you
gotta learn how to work it a little bit
that's true yeah